j'suis dans la prison son museau est
bloqué dans la prison aux hommes
et
je me sens à l'aise comme ça la vérité
l'intérieur à l'extérieur pourrait
mettre sa mort l'un des bagues truc à
faire là bas c'est parti pour la petite
scène du vélo est on bien je sais faire
du vélo et sans les petites roulettes
donc on va en profiter un maximum avec
l'atout qui arrive normalement dans le
var iv ya une heure
la grecque
et pas en pédalo parce que c'est
complètement différent
il faut le faire dans l'eau valider la
taille de l'érection label verges
donc on va utiliser une banane pour
faire un faux zizi sous le drap la faute
juste coupé ça fallait rebondir encore
plus de réalisme c'est plus tendu vers
le haut mais là c'est pour l'équipe de
connaisseurs mais norman qui sut fait tu
fous vous voyez on est quatre heures
c'est l'heure du goûter
mais je me suis jamais les mcr me et
j'ai déjà eu ce problème
tu me fais trop une bonne alors que
cabaret en place s'il vous plaît sans
rigoler en ce sens qu'on sorte merci
doit par contre encore le chanteur fort
colson visage c'était la scène la plus
dure du tournage mais on y est arrivé
martek voilà une grosse ça ne parle plus
du tout peut plus tourner le bus rouge à
lèvres toute la vidéo l'a passée antoine
barillot le réaliser mais qu'est ce qui
se passe là normal tu as l'air de douter
la question est ce que on arrose les
plantes à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
mais le débat est lancé exprimez vous
dans les commentaires youtube
on nous avait dit que c'était la maison
des petits mouchoirs qui racontait son
oui ça et baranov sont elles passées
c'est vrai on regarde ça c'est du bourg
madame
pas de doute c'est l'abolition de la
maison ni bonnet natoye tenté de me
prendre dans les bras mais ça a duré une
seconde nuit à bâle a également cassé
une côte
non ils m'arrêtent et là il fait 30
voilà je vais tomber c'est sûr voilà
ce bouquin
et c'est beau et c'est très beau allez
le stade dans les chaussures on aime ça
puis je déteste le sable
ce sablier du père fouras
bac technique là on s'apprête à tourner
le refrain de la chanson balle moment je
suis tout seul dans cette solitude en
train de faire ils étaient quarante
mille degrés après j'ai un petit parasol
nomme fragile si jamais il se met à
pleuvoir d'un coup tu vois je dis deux
joujoux on baignait la lourdeur à tous
est une femme incroyable devant la
caméra mais hors caméra elle a des
petits problèmes
c'est à dire qu'elle est c'est une p
toggle problèmes gastriques son trip to
le tournage c'était de faire des prout
avec son iphone j'en peux plus je suis
dans je suis
c'est super s'est faite en grâce merci
de ta paix et d'amitié norman en rien je
suis vraiment dans la fredzone aller
clap de fin
il a pas
mais georges sur l'aa
voilà